in nation President Obama announced his  budget proposal for fiscal 2016 today  from the Department of Homeland Security  the four trillion dollar plan includes  middle-class tax breaks tax hikes for  wealthy earners and new infrastructure  investments largely paid for by  corporate taxes the budget the Congress  now has in its hands is built on those  values it helps working families  paychecks go farther by treating things  like paid sick leave and childcare as  the economic priorities that they are it  gives Americans of every age the chance  to upgrade their skills so they can earn  higher wages and it includes my plan to  make two years of Community College free  for Responsible students it lets us keep  building the world's most attractive  economy for high wage jobs with new  investments in research and  infrastructure and manufacturing as well  as expanded access to faster internet  and new markets for goods made in  America